un giorno della settimana che proprio
non sopportiamo un giorno della
settimana che ci sembra sempre più
critico di tutti e immagino che abbiate
capito di quale giorno io sia parlando
bene il lunedì
se guardiamo quello che possiamo sui
social network il lunedì troviamo storia
come questa breve storia triste è il
lunedì o anche gif animate come queste
di spavento disperazione anche rabbia se
fosse possibile
vorremmo arrivare diretti al venerdì
ancora meglio se il venerdì pomeriggio
al di là di quello che noi possiamo
sentire sperimentare e che un po
condividiamo guardando queste immagini
anche la ricerca scientifica di coloro
che hanno studiato le variazioni del
nostro umore nell'arco delle giorni
della settimana ci riportano risultati
molto simili
se voi vedete questo grafico abbiamo da
una parte le emozioni positive che
lunedì raggiungono il livello minimo più
basso e le emozioni negative al
contrario sono a livello massimo
rapporto che si inverte verso il fine
settimana beh direte voi vuoi mettere il
fine settimana con il lunedì
il fine settimana quel bel tempo morbido
la famiglia gli amici gli hobby il buon
cibo e poi arriva il lunedì le scadenze
il capo le cose che non posso proprio
rimandare e quel panino di plastica ha
mangiato davanti al computer
questo malessere per noi è quasi un dato
di fatto qualcosa che diamo per scontato
come se non potesse che essere così ma
deve necessariamente essere così il
nostro lunedì
bene vi do una buona notizia non è così
c'è una forma di intelligenza di cui
vorrei parlarvi oggi che chiamiamo
intelligenza fiorente che vi permetterà
di guardare in modo nuovo e diverso il
vostro lunedì non cercatelo su google
adesso non trovereste non la trovereste
nemmeno nei repertori della psicologia
lì si trova l'intelligenza logico
matematica intelligenza musicale
l'intelligenza creativa l'intelligenza
fluida quella cristallizzata molte altre
ancora
ma non troverete l'intelligenza fiorente
eppure è proprio questo a quelli
intelligenza che è un grandissimo potere
trasformativo e rigenerativo che vi farà
guardare il vostro lunedì per vederlo di
un altro colore è quella intelligenza
che vi permetterà di vedere in modo
integrato il lavoro e la felicità
l'uomo e la macchina l'intelligenza
umana e l'intelligenza artificiale silos
o qualcuno di voi sta pensando a si
belle parole una bella fantasia questa
no ma non ho una storia vera e di una
storia vera che vi vorrei raccontare vi
porterò attraverso tre episodi di una
bella storia che vi faranno capire di
che materia è fatta l'intelligenza
fiorente quell'intelligenza capace di
portare alla massima fioritura la
persona così come le imprese così come
le comunità primo episodio di questa
storia
vi riporto indietro nel tempo siamo
negli anni 50
la situazione è quella di un colloquio
di lavoro
abbiamo da una parte un imprenditore che
sta cercando una figura che potrà
ricoprire il ruolo di capo del personale
la sua è un'impresa in crescita ha
bisogno di qualcuno che sappia
selezionare nuove persone e guidarle
dall'altra parte c'è il candidato a
ricoprire questa posizione
durante il colloquio l'imprenditore
scegliere una strada precisa decide di
non cominciare dal cosa quella persona
dovrà fare decide di non raccontare ha
fatto quale azioni quali comportamenti
pensa siano necessari per ricoprire
quella posizione ma parla di senso e gli
dice questa frase io voglio che lei
capisca il nero di un lunedì nella vita
di un operaio altrimenti non si può fare
il mestiere di manager non si può
dirigere se non si sa che cosa fanno gli
altri
i protagonisti di questa storia sono
giovane furio colombo nella parte del
candidato e adriano olivetti nella parte
dell'imprenditore questa storia ci parla
di ascolto ci parla di empatia della
capacità di mettersi nei panni
dell'altro e compatire patire insieme a
lui vedere un problema farlo emergere e
affrontarlo per orientarlo verso una
nuova fioritura verso una nuova
prosperità questa storia ci parla di
senso e ci parla di azioni perché tante
volte adriano olivetti è stato definito
come un utopista
eppure lui stesso diceva così
beh ecco se mi posso permettere spesso
il termine utopia e la maniera più
comoda per liquidare quello che non si
ha voglia capacità o coraggio di fare un
sogno sembra un sogno fino a quando non
si comincia a lavorarci
e allora può diventare qualcosa di
infinitamente
più grande è un sogno che con i fatti
diventa realtà
suo padre camillo olivetti fondatore
della fabbrica solleva dirgli che la
verità risplende nei fatti non nelle
parole e lui lo sapeva bene perché a 14
anni adriano olivetti da suo padre è
stato mandato in fabbrica a fare
esperienza e questa è un'esperienza che
lo ha segnato profondamente
lui era un ragazzino molto più incline
alla riflessione filosofica che non al
contatto con la macchina e alla vita
l'operatività quotidiana
questa è stata però un'esperienza di
fondamentale importanza per tutto il
corso della sua vita
tant'è vero che sempre finché ha vissuto
il sabato e la domenica adriano olivetti
andava in fabbrica e voleva vederla
vuota perché diceva quando la fabbrica e
ferma i problemi della tecnica i
problemi delle macchine spariscono e il
problema dell'uomo si fa invece più
evidente è il problema dell'uomo che gli
stava a cuore quell'uomo la cui dignità
non finisce la cui vita non finisce
chiusa dentro la tuta da lavoro
voleva vedere gli ambienti della
fabbrica vuoti che piano piano si
riempiono di vita e vedere che cosa
succede quando la persona si trova con
la macchina a fare un compito ripetitivo
e continuo per tante ore ed è per questo
che anche il giovane furio colombo è
stato poi mandato per tre mesi di fianco
agli operai per poterli capire nel senso
di ascoltare in maniera profonda per
poterli poi anche guidare al meglio ma
adriano olivetti non era semplicemente
un brav'uomo un uomo sensibile un uomo
capace di capire bene che cosa c'è nella
sensibilità dell'altro un benefattore
no lui era
un grandissimo visionario la sua visione
quindi quel suo sogno che poi è
diventato realtà era quella di un mondo
materialmente e spiritualmente più
evoluto questo è stato l'impegno di
tutta la sua vita e lui prima degli
altri almeno un secolo prima di tutti
gli altri aveva ben capito che il sogno
che lui cercava era quello di una realtà
in cui il profitto non si è occupato
solo di mietere ma anche di seminare di
continuare a seminare ed è per questo
che la sua da fabbrica di beni è
diventata una fabbrica di bene lo star
bene al lavoro è il primo ingrediente
dell'intelligenza fiorente ce n'è però
poi un secondo che vi racconto con un
secondo episodio che è il viaggio in
america 1925 adriano olivetti decide di
partire per un viaggio in america lo
sente necessario vuole dannatamente
capire perché le fabbriche americane e
riescono a produrre in una giornata 850
macchine quando a ivrea se ne producono
10 allora studia suo padre gli aveva
sempre indicato l'america come la terra
del futuro
in quegli anni si guardava all'america
come al futuro e adriano olivetti al
futuro è molto interessato ha in mente
quel suo futuro di un mondo
materialmente e spiritualmente più
evoluto e cerca il modo di poterlo
realizzare
si prepara prepara un viaggio che dura
cinque mesi e che lo porterà a contatto
con 100 fabbriche tutte li aprono le
porte fuorché una land
wood che alla fine degli anni 50 con un
po di rivincita riuscì a comprarsi a tal
punto da fare della fabbrica di ivrea la
prima multinazionale italiana sbarcare
sul territorio americano che quando
arriva in queste fabbriche osserva e
capisce vede che gli operai americani
sono proprio come gli operai italiane
che non è quella la differenza che la
grande differenza la fa il metodo di
lavoro
sono gli anni del terrorismo della
catena di montaggio di tempi moderni
per intenderci è quella organizzazione
li fa cambiare molto i numeri della
produzione
allora lui che taylor lo conosceva
leggeva il libro dei taylor già dal 1917
circolava in casa sua ma in quel momento
mettendosi in ascolto del futuro ha
capito che quella poteva essere una
strada
e allora qui questa storia però ci parla
di come il futuro deve dialogare col
passato è il passato per lui è quello
della sua famiglia
quella che vedete in questa immagine
adriano olivetti è quello con il cerchio
rosso intorno al volto nasce in una
famiglia dove vive la diversità nasce da
due minoranze padre ebreo madre valdese
figlia di un pastore valdese e perché il
passato e così importante per lui perché
da queste origini che nasce e continua
ad alimentarsi nella sua vita il
rispetto per la persona e per la dignità
dell'uomo
pensate che in casa sua quando ero
ancora un ragazzino suo padre obbligava
già siamo negli anni venti obbligava già
alle domestiche a fare due ore di riposo
al pomeriggio quando non era certamente
un obbligo di legge tanto che questo
signore si imbarazzavano moltissimo a
non lavorare mentre gli altri lavoravano
allora adriano olivetti ha in mente
l'organizzazione scientifica del lavoro
ma in mente anche il suo passato la sua
vita le sue origine e prova a trovare
una strada di far dialogare
il futuro e del passato dice suo padre
che vuole portare ai nuovi metodi di
lavoro il suo padre gli dice bene puoi
fare quello che vuoi ma ricordati di non
lasciare mai a casa nessuno per
l'introduzione di un nuovo metodo di
lavoro perché la non occupazione
involontaria e il peggior male che possa
capitare ad una persona
e allora c'è la ricerca di una strada
nuova che non è la strada del passato ma
non è nemmeno quella del futuro
dell'america e adriano olivetti
organizza al lavoro con le isole di
produzione e introduce i servizi sociali
per i suoi dipendenti per le loro
famiglie e via via per la collettività
questo significa asili questo significa
biblioteche questo significa un'apertura
e una lettura integrata della fabbrica
con il territorio e arriva la bellezza i
migliori architetti del tempo che
vengono coinvolti per la progettazione
della più bella fabbrica che ci fosse in
quegli anni tanto da fare della via in
cui la fabbrica si trova la via più
bella del mondo secondo le parole di le
corbusier e in questa strada una
fabbrica di vetro trasparente integra
l'esterno con l'interno in una visione
legata al rispetto continuo della
comunità
tra i servizi sociali e tra i servizi a
vantaggio delle proprie persone adriano
olivetti voleva il trasporto dalla casa
al luogo di lavoro perché non avrebbe
mai voluto che le persone dovessero
vendere la casa o la terra per un
inurbamento selvaggio che avrebbe
trasformato il bel volto di ivrea che
comunque campagna ai piedi delle alpi
e così stare bene al lavoro è insieme a
fare il bene
ed è così che la triade lavoro
retribuzione consumo lascia spazio a
bellezza lavoro
vita
abbiamo visto così due ingredienti della
intelligenza fiorente stare bene fare il
bene e il terzo è fare bene fare bene
vuol dire portare al massimo sviluppo le
proprie capacità e il proprio potenziale
fare bene vuol dire fare con cura tutto
quello che si fa
adriano olivetti aveva un sogno una
visione che afa che ha trasformato in
realtà il sogno abbiamo detto di un
mondo culturalmente materialmente e
spiritualmente più evoluto per farlo gli
servivano molti profitti per fare molti
profitti li servivano prodotti
eccellenti per avere prodotti eccellenti
e servivano competenze eccellenti e così
la formazione come investimento
la formazione basata sul merito la
formazione basata sul riconoscimento
delle potenzialità e dei talenti di
ciascuno per portarli alla loro massima
fioritura
questo è il caso per esempio di un terzo
episodio è la storia di natale capellaro
natale capellaro è stato un progettista
della diviso ma una macchina
calcolatrice la prima al mondo a fare le
quattro operazioni a restituire anche un
risultato negativo macchina che col
bellissimo vestito di nizzoli trovate
oggi al moma tra gli oggetti del miglior
design il progettista di questa macchina
da calcolo tra natale capellaro giovane
che entra a 14 anni come operaio in
questa fabbrica e per il suo talento per
le sue capacità che hanno trovato un
terreno fertile
intorno a lui riesce a diventare fino
direttore generale tecnico anche
passando attraverso una brutta
esperienza perché un giorno la palla e
cappellaro è stato beccato mentre si
portava a casa del materiale della
fabbrica ma dato che
l'ascolto era diventato materia comune e
comune sentire e comune cultura in
questo luogo è stato ascoltato anche lui
si è cercato di capire perché aveva
sottratto del materiale alla fabbrica e
lì si è capito che lui che era proprio
progettista neri d'animo e va di leva
dibatterete direttiva fare far quello
che oggi ci arrocchiamo un prototipo
cioè essere ha portato a casa dei pezzi
per poter costruire una tastiera e
provare quella che oggi chiameremmo la
user experience prima che la macchina
potesse essere prodotta ed è proprio da
questo ascolto che nasce a
un'applicazione attenta e intelligente
delle regole e che è natale capellaro
non perde di certo il suo posto anzi
continua brillantemente la sua carriera
adriano olivetti credeva moltissimo
nella formazione nelle competenze dal
momento che in quegli anni non c'erano
scuole che permettessero di formare
persone che facessero i meccanici in
maniera eccellente la crea 1935 centro
formazione meccanici una scuola
meritocratica con una forte sbarra tura
all'ingresso ma bellissima perché crea
persone capaci di fare il meccanico in
maniera eccellente e lo fa unendo una
formazione scientifica con le materie
tecnico scientifiche che più possiamo
immaginare legate al ruolo del meccanico
a materia della formazione umanistica ed
è così che questi ragazzi studiano
storia dell'arte storia della filosofia
storia del pensiero economico vengono
portati a vedere delle mostre e guardate
anche a vedere il cinema in quegli anni
allora certo oggi siamo molto lontani
dagli anni trenta e anche dagli anni
cinquanta siamo all'origine di un'epoca
nuova dove
le macchine sono ormai macchine
intelligenti capaci di supportare l'uomo
non solo alleviando lo dalla fatica
fisica ma anche supportandolo nella
presa di decisioni nel giudizio questo
mondo ci può affascinare moltissimo o
terrorizzare anzi diciamo che i dati di
ricerca cd con oggi che siamo quasi più
spaventati che non dall'avvento dei
robot e dell'automazione
però noi sappiamo che possiamo guardare
alle sfide che questo tempo ci presenta
con la sicurezza che ci viene da una
storia che c'è già stata
che se noi ci prendiamo cura
appassionata della nostra intelligenza
fiorente quelle sfide noi potremmo
vincerle con successo e trasformare così
quella breve storia triste da cui siamo
partiti in una lunga storia felice che
dura per tutti i giorni della settimana
grazie
[Applauso]